So up until now, we've pretty much
assumed that whatever we measured is
associated to the thing that we're going
to, that we want to keep track of.
But in reality,
there are a couple things happen.
First of all,
there can be multiple objects.
That's what this cute little airplane
thing is supposed to look like.
And in fact radar,
which is where the birthplace of
multi hypothesis tracking came from.
Had this problem, right?
I get a while bunch of pings back,
there's a bunch of airplanes,
I gotta know which pings go with
which airplanes in order to track,
all the different airplanes.
Or there can be what's known as clutter.
Clutter means there's a lot of stuff
in the environment that has nothing
to do with me.
By the way,
clutter is the basis of camouflage, so
when you take a look at this rattlesnake
whose contour you can just barely see
here, there's all this other stuff that
has nothing to do with it being a snake.
So it confuses your visual system.
Fortunately when
the snake starts to move
if the brush is not moving also then
you can do the association differently.
But in general clutter means that there
are a bunch of measurements that are not
from the thing I'm really
interested in tracking.
The problem is referred to as
the data association problem and
the trick is to determine which
measurements go with which tracks and
which measurements should be ignored.
Which measurements cause
you to start a new track.
These are all things that you
have to do when you do tracking.
So there is a simple strategy and that's
what's indicated here I've got a point
and I've got state now I take some
measurements I might just associate,
I dunno the closest
measurement to my prediction.
So you remember when we were
tracking the contours for
the condensation as our Blake algorithm?
Right?
They took the distance to the nearest
strong contour as if they new somehow
that that was the right contour.
They just made that assumption.
Unfortunately, that doesn't always work.
That clutter problem.
In fact,
one of the points of clutter is for
it to confuse something that's
trying to do that association.
So those of you who watch Tom Clancy
movies or read Tom Clancy books,
like I've done, etcetera,
you know that submarines will jettison
these things that spin around and
make noise and bubbles.
At least I assume they do.
They did in the movies,
they did in the books.
Now the torpedoes have a data
association problem, right?
Which thing that's making noise or
making a signal should it
decide is the real state.
Personally I would think seeing some.
You know, many thousand ton
submarine compared to this
little thing spinning around.
Wouldnt been that hard but
obviously the torpedos arent that smart.
But so it doesnt always work
in the presence of clutter.
There is a most sophisticated
approach to doing this, and
that is You do what's
called multiple hypothesis.
So multiple hypothesis is, well,
okay, I've seen two things now, and
maybe it's one thing, and
I should associate the real
object with the left measurement,
and the right one is clutter.
Maybe it's one thing, and I should
associate the object with the right-hand
one and the left one is clutter.
Or maybe it's two things,
that is a new thing should get created.
Well like I said, there's this
whole area called multi-hypothesis
tracking where you track
all these different things.
You actually can do this using a,
a particles.
Allright?
You can do particle filtering in
a not so obvious way, right?
Each particle Is a hypothesis
about the current state.
So, for example,
a particle can say oh, there are two
such objects, and here's where they are,
or a particle could say,
there is one such object, and this
one is not the right one, et cetera.
So you can do that using
particle filtering.
And in fact I one time told Michael
Eishart I, I said Meaning I said,
you know, for a lot of situations,
I've found that
particle filtering was just a convenient
way of doing multi-hypothesis tracking.
And he said absolutely.
So Michael, if you're out there,
I remember that conversation.
I think he's on the West Coast
having a great time.
So.
So good for him.